watching another big development and its
impact from this past week uh now the
the firm
fact that kids scores uh from all sorts
of educational testing were impacted by
all that time doing classes from home in
fact all of their test scores across the
country markedly sliding and in fact
some of the lowest we've seen in years
ryan walters is the oklahoma secretary
of education and has been looking at
that impact on how to try to prevent it
in the future secretary good to have you
these are pretty startling developments
um what do you make of them
yes sir what we saw here neil
is the national teachers unions failed
our kids anthony fauci failed our kids
and at the time we have a great governor
here in the state of oklahoma governor
kevin st him and i were out in front
demanding school stay open demanding
schools listen to parents because we
heard these heartbreaking stories from
around the state of kids falling behind
we all knew this was going to happen but
the reality is the national teachers
union is more concerned with politics
they're more concerned with power than
they are our kids and our kids needed
schools to be open our parents need more
school choice we need more transparency
and accountability in our public schools
to ensure that money is getting to the
classroom so that every one of our kids
can be caught up to be workforce ready
well what's past is prologue i guess but
i i would like to know going forward
secretary what you think we should do if
we ever had another incident like this
when i had dr fauci on it he thought
that the sweeping measures taken in
retrospect uh probably should not be
taken and i'm wondering uh if you're
getting a sense
that what we've learned from covet is
that we overreacted do you think we
simply overreacted and if something like
that were to come again we don't do that
we don't shut down completely we keep
schools open what
absolutely neil we have
now know definitively it wasn't the
virus that had this major impact on kids
it was our reaction to the virus it was
the federal government pushing shutdowns
it was anthony fauci's orders for states
it was the national teachers union
telling schools to close the reality is
we now know that schools were safe we
now know that our kids impact because of
school shutdown is is going to be
enormous some kids are years behind in
academic learning in the future what we
have to do is what we should have done
all along we should rely on the states
education should be left to the states
the way the schools are operated should
be left to the states and the reality is
nobody knows best for kids and their mom
and their dad parent choice is something
we're pushing tremendously here in
oklahoma governor stood and myself we
want to make sure that parents can
choose for their kids and if parents
wanted an in-person option they should
have been able to receive that this
entire time got it secretary thank you
very very much